à
bon anniversaire maman
sean
j'ai fait une bonne affaire grâce à une
femme au boulot sérieux qu'à voler un
appareil photo ça s'utilise encore
absolument
j'adore celle la cden de penser à ce que
tu pourrais faire si tu faisais ça comme
boulot à plein temps je ne suis qu'un
pauvre petit artiste passé une bonne
soirée monsieur je te rappelle dans ce
but
[Musique]
bienvenue chez ninon c'est une super
voiture monsieur oui la touche pas
tu vois la papauté qu'est-ce qui se
passe une carte black jeunes en sérieuse
way doit bien de ton côté ou leur sert
leur salade nec canon part ça on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps
vous nous quittez déjà la maserati je me
dépêche
le quart jusqu'à ses copains je suis
désolé des chances il a une fille chez
lui un chat blanc qu'est ce que vous
faisiez chez ce type de le cambrioler on
enquête sur une fille en chine et dans
le bureau il désolé de vous décevoir
mais vous allez continuez vous allez
continuer de chercher la faille arrêter
de le harceler
oh qu'est ce qu'il ya on n'est pas en
sécurité
aucun nous c'est bon je te couvre
[ __ ] de part et vous savez les tares
et se font prendre
c'est pourquoi t'es pas dans leurs
petites prises en la maintenant parce
qu'au quai dans la mienne
l'essai
va nous tuer je vous ai dit je vais vous
faire sortir de là